I want everyone to answer this question
all right I'll give you a second to
think about it
now raise your hand if you think you're
a lucky person
just Ramon okay raise your hand if you
think you're unlucky
got it okay put your hands down what
about you Mr Corman was that you didn't
raise your hand
me uh
no I I mean I feel like a lucky person
[Music]
I'm having anxiety or Panic or something
both
what's the difference
I'm gonna need a sub for today
what's bothering you everything it just
feels like I blew the whole thing like I
suck as a person you're not entitled to
a perfect partner or a perfect life
I didn't leave you because you became a
teacher I left because I thought I was
doing what I love with the man I love
how was your weekend it was great
all right good morning happy Monday
everything is a complete disaster you've
had the privilege of expecting
everything to just work out now that
you're faced with some adversity
it could feel like the end of the world
you want to stop feeling like you're
feeling what about this weighted blanket
it costs 250 we can make our own version
you can't make your own version
[Music]
you're feeling less anxious no I'm
really not
I can't stop thinking about all the
things you should have done and why you
didn't do them
I know I can be negative sometimes it's
not how I want to be
nothing is perfect I don't know why
that's so hard for you to see
the question is
what do you do now when your name is
[Music]
[Applause]
just a name